[Music]
uh we have a great panel today to talk a
little bit about the VC Outlook I think
the title says internet and digital
media um and we have a distinguished
panel of uh investors both in China and
actually globally as well um just to
give you a little bit of a preface of
the Venture industry in China
um obviously it started in the
mid90s um and uh it started very small
um today the Chinese VC market in terms
of money being raised in 2011 it
actually surpassed the US um and then uh
last year it kind of us surpassed China
again and there's about a 20 30% Gap in
funds being raised uh big picture it's
gone in 15 uh 20 years um it's kind of
had gone from zero to the same almost
the same size as the US in a very quick
order um and therefore it's been a very
Dynamic uh last couple
decades um and what we're seeing is kind
of new chapters and the dynamis continue
to flourish uh with creating new
companies uh there was a little bit of a
a mini ice Edge uh ice age in
2011 um particularly because there
governance issues accounting frauds and
US made a little bit of a comeback and
so you know China VC Market slowed down
a little bit exits were a little bit
more difficult but now you're kind of
seeing the defrosting happen ever since
YY and Vip Shop went public in 20 uh
2012 and of course we have uh many
recent ones so with a little bit of that
background I'd love to ask this panel we
have Jenny at um Annabelle and Raymond
to you know briefly introduce themselves
their firm and and kind of provid us
their view of the Venture industry today
and maybe the trends that they're
seeing hi everyone I'm Jenny Lee from
ggv uh just a little bit of a background
on ggv we are a us China crossb fund uh
essentially we have the same team
investing both in the US and in China we
manag 1.6 billion uh across both sides
and as far as um
the um being in the market we've been in
China since the year 2000 um and we have
companies like we've been very lucky to
have been involved invested uh
shareholder of companies like Alibaba
China UC web you know YY David mentioned
as well some of the very
Innovative um internet companies in
China obviously the ni s they all coming
to us to ask about you know can I bring
the business model to the US can we find
partners for them in the US uh in the US
we've also you know invested in
companies like Pandora and um Square uh
companies obviously has worldwide
Ambitions as well uh and one of the key
reasons we are partners with them is
also to help them explore uh
International Market um that's kind of a
quick background in terms of uh key
trends I'll just highlight few ones and
you know we can have the panel uh
discuss this where we have invested in
the last two years uh primarily on the
internet front I um talked about a
couple of Trends so the first trend is
really around consumer when we think
about around the consumer it's no longer
about you know for example e-commerce
about you know the consumer going to a
website looking through the whole
millions of skus on tal and trying to
find the items that they need um what
were more interested is we think that
Commerce 2.0 is going towards social
commerce which is around individuals
like and preference uh interest based
intent and and with that we have um been
looking at around Fashion around travel
around home renovation companies like
Mishu to and then house in the US where
you know it's friends you know who share
similar interest and therefore we would
post the next cool skirt that I found on
tal have great reviews and have
Annabelle you know looked at it and buy
that or I look at a great home
renovation idea and I'm able to share
pictures about it not just share
pictures about it but find the site that
can get to it so social commerce uh is
one area that we have made a lot of
investment around so around a person um
in Commerce intent then the other areas
that we've been spending a lot of time
is really the sensor based Hardware
sensor based uh connected devices so
whether I I tend to have a lot of device
on me today I'm just wearing one but I
used to have you know all kinds of
pedometer and things like that and I
think the Next Generation it's all about
data collection and as part of that data
collection analytics it's going to again
drive a lot of um interest based
activity and uh purchase intent or data
services around the individual so that's
also an area where we are spending a lot
of time we think that that's an area
that's going to cross components
Hardware product marketing branding and
essentially disruption in the channel I
think in China um xiaomi is a great
example of course I carry a xiaomi phone
with Hugo Barrow in the audience as well
um and you know I've been the first user
since the first um prototype uh came out
so again you know the whole integration
that comes not just in a final product
but that arise from Smart sensor so
that's across the value chain we have
invested in each of those value chain
and that by itself is a global play it
requires the investor to basically have
Global insight to be able to tap in and
see the end product so that's one key
Trend the second key Trend um that we've
been spending a lot of time on the
consumer side you I'll stop here and you
know we can talk about Enterprise later
on okay it's hard to follow Jenny
because she speaks wayc language my
introduction has always start from a
explanation why a very old fashion media
conglomerate the largest one in Europe I
hope that matters here uh is doing
business VI Venture vehicle in China
given they have a very heavy Legacy
burden to carry that's a $22 billion
annual turnover in a very mature
portfolio that's the parent company for
random house plus penguin via
acquisation the 40% of global trade
publishing Market but that's book our
major cheun of Revenue was coming from
TV you see the idols X factors talents
all over the world even in China the
Chinese audience tend to be more
aggressive than I than I think and music
BMG is coming back to Market and
services uh we have all the businesses
present in China
uh 20 years we didn't go too far still
China's Revenue accounts for less than
2% of our Global turnover then we decide
upon my graduation from B school we
should explore other activities via
different approach I was kind of
inspired by idg why this Media Company
can be a first year VC in China maybe we
should acquire knowledges from The
Innovation Center really is for
incremental Improvement on business
model monetization rather than
disruptive technology you have to
acquire here but if you are looking to
transform a business maybe that's more
relevant for you to really test ideas
that's more relevant and practical in
China how to serve massive audience
under understand Next Generation
consumer Behavior potential advertising
change really I think that's a success
for us for the moment although we didn't
have a home run in terms of VC return
but since 2008 we established an
in-house captive investment fund
starting from girl stage series B plus
now moving towards to rather early stage
series a Investments we made investments
into 25 companies that granted a us a
lot of learning I counted the revenue
for those combined young startups last
year was actually over $1 billion that's
bigger than our current operation was
the 5,000 employees we had in China for
20 years so that's the progress although
we are just a minority shareholder into
those portfolios but the level of
learning was really tangible was
incredible and it grant us a lot of
opportunities to create internal
Business Development projects as well
when Jenny talk about to understand
China Market slightly differently I do
believe that the Innovations coming from
China in a very unique way and the
Chinese gens the the top three is the
Seven Kingdoms are really establishing
the most advanced mobile internet
channels to the next generation of
entertainment and as a as as a media
content driven company we see content
becoming more relevant back into the
picture as a focus for future media
Investments and we'll be really helpful
to really understand how we can play a
role relevance being a value added
content provided to tenson and the like
secondly I think as a media company we
realize majority of our revenue from
advertising advertising itself has to be
redefined to be a different level of
products different level of innovation
different ways of thinking and this has
to be location based this has to be real
time it has to be powered by social
network instant messaging has to be very
experience to Discovery uh as e-commerce
player I think we have a
60,000 people pretty heavy division
doing all the tedious work around the
globe in China I think we still want to
be a dedicated professional provider for
B Supply Chain Services but on the other
hand we also want to tap the market via
successful customerization that's Jenny
and I talk about we actually end up
investing into competing companies one
is Mia the other one is more
because we do believe the social
commerce sector can be much bigger than
the two companies can really attack M
multi-billion multi multibillion sector
I call my mji company is the the is the
sweet home to the gos of girls in China
is purely ugc driven social Community
that's highly relevant I still remember
when the company has only nine people we
wi there made the investment that's our
first serious investment I took them to
our own operational portfol really is
the largest female fion lifestyle home
decoration Parenting Magazine group I
showed them telling them this is the
future generation of uh you know female
lifestyle you should take a look and
find a ways to corporate but they were
being too arrogant saying that oh you
know editorial Superior that's
professional skill set we don't think we
want to compromise on quality we still
want to maintain our brand image that
after nine months is muuji is no longer
interested talking to really because
their traffic is much larger and the
other education to our European
colleague is they were concerned China
is all about aball and traffic there's
no real monetization I showed them the
tens profitability is better than
selling drugs and
secondly I I also showed them the young
startups since day one muu has a
business model they're making money and
they are profitable already after two
years in operation I told them the daily
traffic for the for the for the website
it's already 5 million
on on mobile 1 million on a daily basis
they are getting used to this kind of
numbers but still interesting until I
told them the companies making money
more than $1 million per day so they
think this is something really going so
I'm just providing this information
saying that we're really acquiring the
knowledge the innovation in a very
practical way to transform a pretty old
fashion company I think China is the
place to be Raymond hi I'm I'm Raymond
from West Summit Capital we're also one
of this crossb fund and uh we uh
actually relatively new and we are in
business for roughly four years and we
are uh initially uh sponsored by the by
the Chinese uh you know sou wealth fund
cic Chinese uh China Investment
corporation as their oversee uh Tech
fund arm but now since we have le uh
additional new uh investors around the
world uh become rather uh
independent and uh our uh actually our
investment strategy is pretty simple
that we basically call it China angle
which in the way that we are basically
looking for the companies in the outside
China and to be uh put money in to
become their shareholder and then
leverage our strong uh domes China uh
networks and entrepreneur uh uh Circle
and help the company grow business
Network there so in terms of trend that
I uh probably I will see a couple of
them number one I would I will gr the
two ladies here that in terms of the
China there's a big booming trend is
really much in the gaming space more in
the mobile game I was uh you know I was
uh link former uh CEO of linkon which
was the uh mobile value added Service uh
in China that was like almost 87 years
ago I that was very very booming time
but now I look at this space I almost
have the same feeling with like a crazy
crazy many many companies to come up to
compete in that space particular in
going to the to the mo uh the uh the mo
mobile mobile game space and I believe
that they will grow lots of a great
company there so which which on one hand
is great opportunity on the other hand
we're a little bit careful on the
evaluation on the so-call the bubble but
but overall that's that's great trend if
you give me a sort of a ask me for the
uh stage of this one if I read from 1 to
10 in terms so everything has their
Circle right I still believe this is
relatively early I maybe I give two or
three in the state so means there's
still long way to go there's long long
way to uh hopefully for the investors
like us to make make money on that uh by
the way we invest two companies actually
both here in Valley one called Unity 3D
as as the is a software uh uh platform
for the mobile game on the uh browser
game on the mobile game which has been
grow tremendously very very successful
almost uh nowaday the overall download
the game download on the App Store more
than 50% of games are using Unity uh and
and software certainly Unity is also in
the transition period going to have a
bigger uh future in that space the other
compan is very very interesting is
called the twitch if you have you know
the the twitch the the the people do
that is interesting name it's it's very
interesting model is like watching other
people play games which is another San
Francisco bit so that's very much like
Jenny said the world is changing to this
because not only watching they can also
chatting like a little bit like a YY
kind of model so you're like social
media with the the video game that's in
that kind of a uh circle is very very
interesting Company the company has grow
very very tremendously with huge you
know the the traffic and momentum so
that's uh very interesting we'll
continue looking for this hopefully the
Eco Eco system the component in in this
multi median game industry the second
Trend I would say that was the I
consider as the globalization of Chinese
companies I've been in this business for
a long time I've been talking I've been
hearing that the Chinese company always
going to go to abroad looking for
opportunity so on so forth but I in the
past six months a year I've never seen
such a strong momentum and and I think
uh uh D Duncan said one very funny word
I want I want borrow his word called the
we call Beijing now the Beijing spelling
b a y i j i n g Beijing is because the
Bay Area and Beijing is so converged
into one one place thanks to Duncan
great invention on on that word which I
really like that so you know very often
you see people here in the valley that
is supposed to your friend that you
otherwise see say in China in Beijing
and then the know take the uh another
example the Hugo is sitting there now is
recently you know join shiai this is
evidence that Chinese company now very
very seriously looking for opportunity
and also 10 cense Wishin has been very
popular outside not only in China but
outside China almost every uh major
Chinese particular internet company has
set up some kind of operation uh in in
the Bay Area were in us so I see that
Trend not only people come here to
acquire the sort of first of all at very
very high high level I think everybody
every CEO from China would benefit to
say I really like the cicen Val sort of
a culture i i call state of mind so
that's something their their benefit for
their you know intellectual and spirit
and then they looking for some
technology and then they potentially
looking for expansion outside China and
then
that's that's where they become so-call
global company versus any Chinese
company I definitely see that Trends
going on so which means that also bring
to lots of potential opportunity for
potential merger acquisition investment
or even complete 100% of acces of any
future us company so I think that's
something very significant yeah I think
let me let me transition into a series
of questions here you know as Raymond
said you know for most Chinese companies
especially Venture back even as far as 5
years back IPO was pretty much the only
exit available um domestic Chinese
internet companies weren't large enough
or they didn't have the mindset of
mergers and Acquisitions or going
outside of China to buy companies um and
at the same time you know more
traditional Chinese companies you know
were not willing to pay ridiculous
prices for for startups today it's
completely different um you know you
have do just bought 911 net the third
largest App Store um Android app store
they also have IOS too um for about $
1.9 billion that was the largest m&a um
Ali Baba is buying a couple companies um
as we speak and when you put all that
together what you're starting to see is
um a very similar Trend that Silicon
Valley saw which is you know in Silicon
Valley actually most of venture exits
are m&as and in China it's just starting
to happen and it's becoming a realistic
outcome so let me let me talk about let
me um ask each panelist uh three
questions um uh so first let me ask
Jenny you know there's been an angel
boom in the US um obviously when times
are good you know incubators and Angel
Investments pop up it's happened in 99
2000 as well many incubators ended up
being incinerators in the US by 2000
three four times this time people say
it's a little different because you know
the cost of capital to start companies
now are much lower etc etc um you know
talk a little bit about you know how the
angel movement in China's impacting
Venture Capital as well as entrepreneurs
and are there any differences between
what's going on in the US and China uh
yeah so you know this as a um expansion
stage Capital fund this is a great trend
for for us like it's fantastic for us we
tend to come in about 50% in B round um
we have about 20 30% in a round so what
we do do um very clear within our
ecosystem is the Angel Community talk
about China first so in China I think
the last few years uh it's been a bit
more um the angel Community is smaller
and it's been a bit more about super
Angels right so whether it's the chanan
or lein uh ecosystem I I think they've
all come from entrepreneurs who had a
network they were part of say tenen or
Buu or you know Alibaba and therefore
when they came out to be Angel they come
with a lot of people um uh relationship
and therefore they were able to
capitalize on that seed investment for
where we are uh at ggv uh it's it's
fantastic for us right obviously we are
early investor in Alibaba one of my
other partners sat on the board of BYU
for six years so this are big ecosystem
system where we are invited to the
family so we would tend to discuss with
the angels in terms of what's the right
sector and what's the right Trend I
think fast forward um in the last one
two years we're starting to see that
second layer of angels come out you know
so these are the guys who may not be
from 10 years ago or Founders you know
of of um public companies in Chena
lingon you know it's really really was
um but really the all GS right the
employee early employees at puu early
employees at tensen early EMP employees
at Alibaba and then the next Generation
whether it's chiu um or the game
companies I think we're also seeing them
come out um and within there there are
sub sectors so you may have Angels um
there are in gaming there are angels
Commerce uh and things like that so so
for us we we actually like it we think
that China actually doesn't have enough
early uh even seat qualified type
investors and this this entrepreneurs as
they as they bring capital and also that
willingness to spend time with other new
entrepreneurs uh in the market it would
help to educate the base of
entrepreneurs coming out from China so
10 years ago when when when we were in
China nine out of every 10 entrepreneurs
we meet firsttime entrepreneur we have
to explain we have a Chinese translated
version of the English ter term sheet
and we have to explain every single
Clause you know what it means what
what's a Redemption Clause what's a
liquidation clause and kind of bring
them up but today I think the
entrepreneurs we're starting to see
probably out of 10 now five out of 10
entrepreneurs are zero entrepreneurs so
they have done startups before whether
they fail or not they've done it before
and they are more educated about the
process and therefore they are also more
uh Network today so the team the quality
of the team that's being put together is
definitely you know a notch higher uh as
well so I I do like the trend um I don't
see those um angels as competitors i'
rather see them as great uh partners and
today you know whether it's the team
from UC web the team from YY we continue
to see that fresh blood that's coming
into the market um which overall it's
great because going internet is a sector
where every three five years you have
this brand new company that comes out
with a pretty innovative business model
and so having that fresh blood Angel
Community you know to it I think is
especially Bri as well yeah it's it's
very interesting in the US the angel
boom probably started about two and a
half years ago and now you know there's
actually quite a large number of
startups that's starting to struggle to
figure out the series A's and the series
B post that angel seed round and my
guess is that in China over the last
year a lot of the Angel Investments were
done um with with um with fervor and
probably in about a year from now you
kind of see a little you know the over
supply of startups and then BC is trying
to figure out which ones are the good
ones and I think you know it's quite
it's mirroring what's happening a little
bit in the US um so anab I'd love to you
know since you're with Burman um you
know we're seeing this major shift to uh
mobile uh in China in particular you
know Android's been very successful um
70% of the smartphone market
um and also creating great indigenous
players like xiaomi and of course uh um
Legend Lenovo groups doing quite well
with the phones um in in the US we've
seen the shift from Internet to the
mobile and many internet companies are
struggling you know for in terms of
advertising you know an eyeball on the
internet was a little was worth was
easier to monetize than an eyeball on
the mobile phone but at least it's still
you know at least you can still monetize
on mobile um and the Gap is getting
closer but um but in China the shift to
mobile was quicker larger in
scale and
monetization GAP is so big right so
suddenly a lot of internet companies
when their audience shifted 50% to
Mobile in a year they couldn't make
money off the mobile and they were
having they were struggling and and I'm
wondering when do you think this you
know mobile will truly start creating
enough money in the ecosystem of course
gaming as Raymond said we know is a you
a slam dunk in China but outside of
gaming when is mobile really going to
make money in China well that's a big
question a real question to us that's
why we pick China as the testing field
for us to move most aggressively on
testing the potential monetization given
the market we have no Legacy and no
potential of canalization to the problem
you mentioned in our established us and
European market in our internal price
conflicts so I think definitely mo
mobile gaming will be the first
phenomenal but the consumptions on
mobile reading on watching video and
listening to music are still there we
are in the hope that uh as long as the
ecosystem continue to evolve people will
be willing to pay for that not only
advertising funded my personal view will
be mobile advertising tend to be
overestimated because it's a hard to
measure and it takes really long process
to educate and return the result but a
cynical person would say nobody in China
is ever going to pay for content on
their phone I agreed and nobody in for
for the moment but actually they are
paying they just don't know they're
paying China mobile for 5.7 billion
dollars worth of run and run bags every
year that's the purchasing power that
was just robbed by China mobile I
definitely don't think this game can and
L for long no one will be really happy
for owning 80% of market share you're
screaming for competition there will be
there but do on had 90% of the market
share but you you see the competition
coming in I really see China mobile is
also under pressure and tenson really
are Reinventing The antire Tao dominated
ecosystem in future there will be
additional mobile distribution channels
maybe via Vin and V chat maybe even via
VIA w war and I I really see this in the
very beginning content for for example
taking music as example was only vied as
a tool to acquire traffic as long as
people listening to music and come to
the website we can firstly monetize via
maybe news and later Ecommerce uh this
is just only a TR gaming this is just a
traffic driver but I think those big
internet companies will also run be
running out of gross topics as someday
they will reconsider the Ste sustainable
consumptions on the fundamental
entertainment formats being raing being
music being radio of course the format
of content has to be reinvented but they
will have the incentive for tenson by
alib Baba to package the product
differently to sell it what we can do is
continue to be paranoid investor into
those content consolidate and getting
ready for the next more aggressive move
where do we start has to be China
another reason because I think Chinese
people we talk about big data in the
morning session it's the most massive
skill of audience and secondly they're
the least sensitive to privacy so if you
want to start a a big data trading
convenience package content service has
to be starting from China yeah I agree I
agree with Annabelle it was it was quite
remarkable one of our Associates in the
Beijing office started paying I think
it's about two R&B per month for QQ
music where and I said well you know are
you doing that because you feel guilty
because for 10 years you were
downloading for free or you know do you
is this a truly good service or you know
you don't want to be caught you know uh
torting or sh you know downloading some
something from shle um and uh you know
he said you know this service is good
and you know because it's only two R&B
per month I'm I'm willing to pay and you
know yes I feel a little bit less guilty
and at the same time I get slightly
better content and so it's very
interesting to see how you know people
in China are starting to pay for Content
which I think 5 years ago you know I
don't think anybody was paying for cont
institutional level I think five years
ago nobody paid for our Idol and expect
Factor now they're paying serious money
to wise yeah AG so if I were to add the
um expected monetization for mobile for
this year just for games mobile games uh
from China is expected to exceed the
billion dollar so you know when we look
at mobile we do see it as content
Commerce and community communication um
one of our portfolio company on the
mobile um gaming distribution platform
they actually have so the conversion for
PID every hundred user that downloads
their
games the 30 of them actually end up
paying for mobile conversion 30% paid
conversion is very high if you look at
traditional PC or browser the conversion
is less than 3% and the a average our
pool so average um Revenue per user
who's paying for different types of game
content is around $20 a month US dollars
so it's not low so when we were shocked
when we saw the data because the
conversion to pay conversion is high the
amount is High um and and when users are
paying sometimes it's direct for the
content sometimes it's in the form of
virtual currencies which they can use to
make themselves look better right so if
we ask 10 cent they're starting to sell
stickers on WeChat what stickers right
so it's again virtual items that the
users uh in China they're willing to
have this stock value wallet and then be
able to sell to show themselves in
different form so the monetization uh as
we think about China is expected to take
a very different form than just
monetizing off the traffic from the US
and and that's where I think uh it's
caused for a lot of excitement and
that's actually good segue for um I'm
going to ask a question about Innovation
to Raymond um which is you know in many
ways Japan and Korea have paved the way
how to monetize mobile um if you look at
WeChat WeChat Wasing is actually a u I
hope Martin's not in the room anymore
but um you know waying is actually a
copy of a company called caca talk in
Korea um and it's yeah and it's not it's
and by the the way Martin and I had a
discussion yesterday about this and you
know he he acknowledges um okay and and
and what's what's uh what's interesting
is um and of course line is very big in
Japan they both have started games um
and they have I mean they're they're
stickers of course and then uh their
revenue is going through the roof and so
it'd be very interesting to see China
when wa we at waying starts putting
games they um a lot of money is going to
flow that way away from a lot of the
mobile game players today uh but at the
same time I think it will make the
market much bigger and great opportunity
for new developers and so so Raymond I'd
love to ask a question about Innovation
um which is you know I think a lot of
Chinese um internet companies have
probably for almost 15 years called hey
you know it's a copy of something in the
US or something in Europe or something
in in in Japan um or even Korea um and
in 2012 we saw something very
interesting which is when you look at
the two companies YY and Vip Shop that
went public um there are no you know
major companies um that have been as
successful as YY um in terms of
real-time communication during the games
yes those features are available
elsewhere but why why you know was the
first where it could take a company
public and be multi-billion based on the
business model um you look at Vip Shop
and you know you see Guilt has been
somewhat successful in the US but at but
at the end of the day you know it still
can't go public it's not it's not you
know doing like super super well whereas
Vip Shop in China takes you know similar
model and then it's the first one to go
public you know3 billion dollar in
market cap and what what you're kind of
seeing is models that may not work
outside of China or is doing you know
maybe too small but you go to China and
you suddenly have
this localized Innovation finally
working as opposed to you know oh this
is the Yahoo of you know Yahoo Yahoo of
China or the Google of China and like in
the past and so I I'm seeing subtle
changes and um unique in Innovation but
at the same time
somebody would argue right well yeah but
the fundamental technology for YY is
still you know it's realtime you know
game communication that existed just
happens to be China's a big market for
that and at the end of the day you know
probably seven to eight out of startups
in China that we see you know it's still
you know they will often refer to well
in the US there's this idea and that's
that's what we're trying to do it's
still about 80% when do you think China
will cross the bar where more than half
of these startups are going to come with
their own ideas and uniquely
Chinese well I I think this still going
to be a long time okay the the U the the
Chinese people's
mentality is starting from the actually
potential huge domestic Market once you
have your product doesn't matter was a
virtual product was a solid you know uh
uh product that you can sell a different
layer of people you know every know
purchasing power come this way right can
sell you're you know iPhone S on this
level xiaomi is or you know there's some
kind of a uh lower level so that's why
the the Chinese people one I we had the
argument one day to say oh Chinese
entrepreneurs are compare with the
entrepreneurs in City valy a lack of
innovation which in a way I say agree or
disagree in the way the US citicon
Valley entrepreneurs are very good at in
at the soall change of the world they
have Innovation that to tell the
existing 4un 500 1,000 CEO to say you
know what this is the way this is the
way that the world is going you got to
follow this trend but go looking to the
Chinese entrepreneurs they say this is
the way customer not paying our money
they're not they're not paying paying
they're not waiting to pay for this one
they're not willing to use this product
but we have the Innovation to find a way
how to charg it so that's the Innovation
sort of in Chinese way okay so therefore
if you talk about YY right YY is very
typical the the situation is like know
basically it start with something called
the chatting on on game the jny was
there however how do you find the
monetize of that right the other example
that I know there's some competitions
here the chiu 360 right they basically
they their Innovation you say in the
world people offering something called
the Security Antivirus software by
chatting people this is like a no Brer
yes everybody PID for that for the
protection of your know desktop they say
you know what we offered entire things
free okay then all of a sudden you have
lots of people using that then they
start finding some other way to to use
uh to use the monetization so I think
from that point of view you're going to
continue see Chinese entrepreneurs and
find a way because unique situation that
to how to find the best way to serve the
end users need while let them to pay for
that versus on really on the business
model side to create a sort of
innovative business model or technology
to have that so therefore I think that's
more the the my view on that you know
that's
basically I I bu that you know I I think
um in terms of monetization service
models I think
Strat sales strategy so so for yeah but
since I have one minute left let me ask
each panelist how many more years until
you see the majority where a Chinese
startup is going to bring their own
unique Innovation that's not related to
you know outside of China just just just
make a guess how many how many years
later will that start happen so so I
have a different view from Ray I think
Innovation is here today if you Define
innovation as only technology you know
based level research type Innovation
then I think that's too narrow a scope
for Innovation Innovation is about
building sustainable big companies that
can go on for the next 5 to 10 years or
even longer and Essence to that
Innovation is business model which is
monetization so as R had a couple of
examples before I'm completely uh on it
I think today China 2.0 right so so uh
I've definitely bullish on China I've
been there for the last 10 years uh I
have seen in the LA last five years so
much innovation in business model for
Chinese companies um that you know I
don't think I want to be anywhere else
um so I believe it's there today but I
asked a different question I I
acknowledge the business model I
acknowledge the service model if you
look at technology how many more years
do you think it will take
for well even for technology right I
mean when you talk about W technology
their voice backend network carries more
voice minutes than Skype for the whole
year in in why single month of operation
so I I do think that it's but but that's
about you know buying more servers and
you know um and and working scalable
architecture well so I think when it
comes to voice um real time interaction
by itself there's a lot of recognition
technology that goes behind it uh as so
but there's there comes a time though in
the technology you know VC industry
where technology does have to start
playing a role and maybe I should ask it
that way which is when do you think
technology will play a larger role um
you know be um you know because if you I
mean you know we live it every day right
if you compare to Silicon Valley maybe
you know in Silicon Valley today
probably four out of 10 are technology
companies that come through our doors in
China it's maybe one out of 10 and so
you know when do you think that will
equalize it's it's going the long way
yeah my view how about you Annabelle
well that's going to be a long way to
compete really with Silicon Valley but
it's happening now to Europe already if
we actually demoed the vat product
together with WhatsApp imprint of
worldone and all H&M and all our
potential clients and customers here
they were blown away by the robustness
of Technology V had is certainly much
more advanced and sophisticated
in terms of Technology yeah and I agree
with your great example we regret a
great deal for Vip Shop I personally
dismissed this opportunity because we
invested in mum V in Europe it didn't
grow too big and we invested in by wiip
here in us so for to Hon for only $100
million so we miss the multibillion
dollar opportunities nowadays we already
funding difficulty when wrting
investment proposal back to I was the
comps so when it comes to muuji I can no
longer Define this is a Instagram plus
Pinterest Commerce so something unique
is really happening now in China I see
five years time I don't know who else
but in my own portfolio I will see
something really unique technically from
China we account for 50% great on that
note I want to thank the wonderful
panelists I think I'm over time already
um so uh I want to pass the but Tom back
to Duncan thanks I'd like to thank you
thank
[Music]